we thought that maybe if Trump became
elected if anyone thought that were
possible the tweets would stop he is
tweeting regularly here is one of his
latest conspiracy tweets in addition to
winning the electoral college in a
landslide I won the popular vote if you
deduct the millions of people who voted
illegally what's your take on him saying
tell you what Marco's first of all it's
delusional yes totally insane
nobody believes that who studies
elections or election patterns but
number two this is what is scary about
it when he says that he's really sending
a signal to Republicans all over this
country Republican leaders and what he's
saying is we have got to suppress the
vote we have got to make it harder for
poor people people of color immigrants
elderly people to participate because
they may be voting against us and that's
scary stuff my own view is we have got
to work overtime to bring more people
into the political process not make it
harder for people to participate but
that's really what he is saying in that
week here's the other one
today's Trump this is just today and
there's it feels like every day you wake
up to a new one nobody should be allowed
to burn the American flag if they do
there must be consequences perhaps loss
of citizenship or year in jail two
responses to that let's see we have
massive income and wealth inequality we
have 43 million people living in poverty
we have to deal with climate change
which is threatening the existence of
the planet and he's talking about three
people who might burn the American flag
but the second point there there's a
hidden message in that and that is be
careful if you are prepared to dissent
now the Supreme Court has said is that
that is within constitutional framework
that that is something that is cut
that's a form of expression but what he
is really saying is if you want a really
dissent be careful it's not just the
American flag here we're watching you
that's what's scary about that so on a
personal level when you as a citizen
forget the fact that you are a senator
it you you're scared right now
do you to worry about this man or well I
worry about the future of this country
yeah
I worry about somebody who wins an
election who's the cornerstone of his
election was bigotry was attacking
mexican-americans Muslims trying to
divide us up I worry very much about a
man who thinks that climate change is a
hoax when the scientific community tells
us that it is the most serious
environmental crisis facing this planet
and if we don't get our act together the
kind of planet we're going to leave to
our kids and grandchildren will be in
serious problem with serious problems so
I worry about those things and more
you